un nuevo otoño caliente en cataluña el
ex presidente de carles puigdemont
establecido en bélgica fue puesto en
libertad por decisión de una corte
italiana el líder independentista fue
detenido el jueves nada más aterrizar en
el aeropuerto de cerdeña pretendía
reunirse con el presidente regional y
asistir a un festival folclórico catalán
la isla de cerdeña cuenta con cerca de
20.000 catalanoparlantes dubra nuevo
look habrá que valorar si realmente hay
motivos para que el presidente
puigdemont sea extraditado a españa o no
año o menos
tres jueces deberán determinar si dan
luz verde a la orden de extradición
mientras deliberan el ex presidente
tendrá que aguardar en la isla contra
puigdemont que sea una euroorden de
entrega por delitos como el de sedición
emitida por el tribunal supremo español
el presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez pidió respeto a las decisiones
judiciales lo que tiene que hacer es
comparecer y someterse ante la justicia
en marzo puigdemont y otros dos líderes
independentistas perdieron la inmunidad
de europarlamentaria
sin embargo su defensa esgrime que el
tribunal general europeo había
suspendido la euroorden
la orden judicial data de septiembre y
octubre de 2017 cuando el gobierno de
cataluña celebre un referendo de
separación de españa' parte del gobierno
fue encarcelado mientras los demás se
establecieron en bélgica la detención ha
provocado manifestaciones en barcelona
en bruselas y en la isla de cerdeña y
calienta el tenso clima político en
plena negociación de los presupuestos en
el que el gobierno de pedro sánchez
necesita el apoyo de los
independentistas y con la mesa de
diálogo entre el gobierno de españa y la
generalitat de cataluña reanudada